bonjour c'est le ramoneur quelques
milliers de cheminées sont ramenés par
an pour la sécurité des yvelinois abois
absurdes ou à gaz
le ramonage est une obligation une fois
par an pour les assurances en cada 110
ont dit deux fois par an c'est pour les
gens qui brûlent énormément dès qu'on
sort des quantités genre style un sac
poubelle ou de sacs poubelle je suis là
on force les gens faire un deuxième pour
leur propre sécurité
si on joue pas avec le feu commence en
france on enregistre un incendie
domestique toutes les deux minutes
parmi ces incendies les feux de cheminée
sont une cause récurrente que
j'entretiens tous les ans je vois pas la
différence en fait c'est juste si je le
faisais pas tous les deux ans ou trois
ans éventuellement là je constaterai une
différence mais là je le fais une fois
par an donc il ya je vois aucune
différence quand je fais une
un flux un feu de cheminée si les terres
à manille ou pas je vais ouvrir une
fenêtre pour faire un appel d'air comme
50 grammes ramon la suisse à la ramène
dans la cheminée pour éviter la suite
qui s'accumulent dans les conduits les
ramoneurs ou quelques techniques et
conseils pour éviter une cheminée
boucher aura bonne jusqu'à qu' il n'y a
plus rien qui tombent du conduit ou à
part quand c'est du bistrot du lycée de
la sfi qui s'agglomèrent le fait de
brûler des bêtises les cas j'ai des
cartons les trucs comme ça où des bois
traité et ça provoque du bist ça fait
des morceaux comme du charbon de bois et
c'est ça qui provoque des heures 30 un
bon entretien des conduits de cheminées
de gaz ou de fioul sont nécessaires et
doivent être ramenées pour éviter les
incendies